hey guys i'm not sure if you've heard of
a game called phasmaphobia it's
one of the scariest games i've played in
a very long time
i've been live streaming it for you and
we figured
it would be a good idea to cut the best
parts out
and put it in this one gigantic long
video and an extra thank you to
jacob for editing this you will see
there's some little treats in this video
so enjoy poop
is that it i see you
what the hell just happened something's
like
oh my god is that is it
[Laughter]
what the hell is that noise
what there was these cans
how do i pick how do i pick things up
what are you doing here
what are you doing should one of us stay
have stayed behind because what's the
point of filming things
like do i leave it somewhere
hello coming in
nancy drew oh my god it's so dark no
nancy davis
you confuse me how do i use my
flashlight
again uh f here
nancy nancy
nice house your haunting here nancy
davis
nancy davis oh i found a piano
can i put this down
can i play oh my god
i hear something in here there's
something
in here that's my radio thing what
i've got a radio what are you telling me
before you do these things how did you
get it out
cute
this creepy mannequin sun hill vibes
right here
why is your flashlight like that
it's a uv flashlight so i can see spooky
ghost cheers and stuff
nancy such a cute little teddy bear
i hate bathrooms
look it's a ghost thing it's ghosting on
the mirror
nancy
boy nancy get out of here
though actually was kind of scary you
couldn't do that again
i can't believe we weren't turning
lights on what's wrong with us
fancy fancy
nancy nancy no no no i just tried turn
my and i didn't want to turn on
what all the lights come out because i
don't know you did something
hello is that your cpu i don't know
where you are
what is up traveler nation
i'm your host killer keemstar let's
get right into the news
you're terrifying
where did you go right so did you
actually read about what she wanted or
something
i'm just going to walk around the whole
entire house with my heat sensor
up fair enough
would go a lot faster if i could uh
do the oh oh scheiser
oh god braden come with me yes i'm
behind you
get get your box out your radio
get it out fancy nancy davis
nancy davis are you in this washing
machine
she's gone now what
are we are we locked in here no
nancy davis
nancy come to us nancy nancy nancy
nazi nancy dave oh look is there
anything in here
nancy davis is this your car
it's very nice
oh the lights flickering oh my god oh my
god
oh my [ __ ] that's so dangerous
[Music]
what the [ __ ] nazi davis lego braden i
know he's annoying but
stop [ __ ] oh my god
nancy please leave me alone
i'm gonna leave
[ __ ] brayden i'm out of here braden are
you there
braden why aren't you speaking to me
[ __ ] oh okay good we got paul
brayden brayden
braden
are you not talking on purpose
i'm out of here
why are your nostrils glowing
um what are they called again
uh mary martin what's happening
yeah mary martin is that what you were
asking yeah what's it called again
[Laughter]
one more time yes you know
but it's still good
mary martin
no it's got to say mary are you around
um we come in peace it's not an alien
mary mary in the mirror
bloody mary bloody mary bloody mary
however oh there's a bone i found a bone
oh
sweet wait let me take a picture where
is it
where is it yeah i've got to take a
picture of it that's what that person
said on
in the chats where is it i can't see it
there oh here
cool wait i need light
thank you
got it i got the bone
mary martin we found your bone
i'm gonna keep on the lookout for this
uh special room
that was not me
special room in the dark
yeah yeah
do you think it's downstairs it's good
chance
i didn't try all these rooms though
i can't see anything i swear i can hear
something moving down here
um it's flashing oh my [ __ ] yes
[Music]
[Applause]
stop i uh why
i just don't get it i always catch you
[ __ ] watching this sick [ __ ]
this is sickening look i'm dead
oh my god this is so cool
you take me with you take me with you
i want to come with you did you follow
me out of the last place
so do we click the the pad the number
pad
i thought we've been here before have we
yes this was the first house but it's
okay
we didn't do very well so let's try
again
can we turn the lights on there we go
basement
see a little light here i'm gonna put
the camera down on like
the kitchen oh [ __ ]
no it's not me it wasn't me
it wasn't me it wasn't me
i've got the camera i can see the camera
i'm coming back in
oh jesus
there's like the boy he cries
i thought he was still in the house
fox i thought you were in the house
oh it's a baby's bedroom it's a bit
creepy
yeah it is and i can't find the
flashlight or the light switch
here it is oh [ __ ] it's not working
brayden
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay um where are
you
i found a bone kind of bone where are
you here
william williams please do not hurt me
i um
[Music]
oh my god so scared of me
it was it was full full thingies
he's in here he was in here
it's gone all right
i'm gonna put the book in the kids room
because he clearly is
doing stuff in there no i don't think he
is though
i think it's just random rooms we
haven't even been upstairs yet
he's in here he's in here he's in here
he's in it
we mean you no harm
put the [ __ ] in here did you already put
the book down
yeah he's gone now the bloody hell is he
in here
william williams which one of us do you
like the least
[ __ ] oh so oh
the [ __ ] the bunny rabbits moved what
bunny rabbit
where are you that rabbit disappeared
i've only got two uh [ __ ]
i've only got two i might die oh my god
wait where are you all right okay let me
come with you oh hello
sorry sorry it was my ear
oh my god
[Laughter]
where did you go in the basement
where is the radio just in the living
room
oh in the living room
i cannot see anything oh my god
i saw it i saw it i saw it i got it
no no no no i can't oh it scares me
ow i thought it was my you
[Music]
yes i'm dead i thought it was by you i
was coming to you to take a picture
okay time to leave
i love how both of us just keep dying
the other one's just like
see ya bye
are you looking at my dead body i can
see you
don't you dare t-pack me just go just go
yeah oh look the fuse box is out here
this time that's quite nice oh actually
is it is it no it's not it's just
decor
okay sixteen point
three something oh we've been here
before as well sorry i keep picking the
same ones
because i don't know what we have done
what we haven't
yeah i think you're right there's a
little
it does sound like there's a sink or
something
like i can hear something weird
i i don't know where oh braden
i'm scared
i saw missed or something i don't know
you've gone
oh [ __ ] hell oh i'll see you
you've trapped yourself in a bathroom by
the looks of it it's not a bathroom
but i was trapped i was scared
i can hear something can you hear
something
dirty water
okay we found oh my god brayden
braden it's gonna come out in the corner
in the corner
what corner what's going on
he's gone he's gone he's gonna take
pictures
oh my god i'm gonna die
yeah that's what i did scared
scared this has got to be the room
yeah this is definitely the room without
a doubt we just need to go back to the
van
and get some more stuff please don't
hurt us
we just want to go back to our van
okay let's go what's your temperature
like
it's not bad it's 18 17.
what's his name now we haven't found
anything we haven't found any freezing
temperature oh my god
that those are shot okay uh donald's
clark
donald clark i'm coming
no don't say his name oh this is bad
don't say his name don't say his name
because you'll anger him
because someone said say his name
i'm coming if i can remember the way
oh turn around turn around me yeah
yes you
you've gone past it yeah here we go
there we go am i holding my crucifix
be gone
where are you be gone okay
um do you think it's in this one can you
use your emp for me please
donald clark
why you're [ __ ] up
on evil spirit
by the power of
the lord
[Music]
[ __ ] i died
[Music]
it doesn't work i was following
him out with my crucifix it didn't work
oh god i'm through the floor
my body's through the floor
i can hear her still i can
hear her oh i can see it too
[ __ ] okay i'm just gonna lean
oh it's still there
it's the grudge the grudge sounds ghost
can't open doors
i shut the door please do not put f in
chat because i'm going to escape
oh you look quite sinister look at just
me
looking down oh my god wait you do that
so the
chat can see
i love how they look at the ceiling
it's crazy i mean that is some serious
back strength and mobility
she had the key no one picked up the key
to the house
we're great at our job
seems fine in there oh no i'm getting
some activity down here
wait this the same oh it's a
bloody kid's bedroom again there's a
bone i found a bone
oh yes
bone evidence if a dancer
so i'm using the car key
i found another key i keep finding keys
can you tell me your name [ __ ]
the front door just closed it's [ __ ]
spiked it's massive the lights are
flicking
oh brady i can't close
let's go mental
jesus yeah there's something there
i mean someone had a point here they
said if one of the objectives is to find
a room
below like zero whatever celsius
that isn't the other clue uh
below freezing temperatures
in the journal i'll come i'll come join
what's
it's getting chilly the door's locked um
okay i think you might be dead
activity spikes massively
are you dead
i can't get in it's flicking
you're good you're safe you can exit
i think we need to leave i think we
should leave
we need we need to figure out what ghost
it is
i'm coming
hello
oh my god hiding in that cupboard is
terrifying
all right let me just try and ask it
some questions now you're here i feel
[Music]
oh oh oh oh let me get in i'm coming in
turn off your flashlight
what was the objective 10.
i can hear something
how old are you
please don't do that
i'm leaving i think it's still there
all the lights just went off inside i
don't want to go back in i think it's
ready to kill
it's definitely around there i saw her
all right
hello there
activity is very high
i can see her i saw her i tried to take
a picture
she's wobbling around for the house
your sanity is dropping yeah well i just
[ __ ] saw her she just went right in
my face
are you in the cupboard still yes
sanity's good come on
this is one angry kid bye angry kid see
ya
there's a high school there's a high
school there's high school
do you want to do that one yes
this is a school bus spooky school bus
what's her name jennifer miller no show
yourself no
don't listen to the weird man or else
don't
listen to the weird man okay
i think it's time to go upstairs i don't
think there is is that no there is
the stairs are here yeah this is what i
mean
you sure yeah look have you been all
around
the [ __ ] phone is ringing did you
hear that
pick that up please no where are the
phones do you know where the phones are
did you see your phone i think it might
actually come from upstairs because it
it's upstairs or something it's down
here it's down here where down here
where where i'm going
is this it will both be able to hear it
is that it if you stay here i can go up
and trigger it again because it
it always goes off whenever i start to
go upstairs
fine fine oh look the generator is
underneath the stairs that's good to
know
jennifer miller ring the phone no
oh it's not ringing now i'm going
upstairs
see ya split up this is this is how you
die no i don't want to split up
this is how you're doing a horror movie
i know jennifer miller
make it chilly
because this is now getting silly
i'm going back downstairs i'm gonna look
for that phone
i think the lights might have gone out
what
yeah maybe we did too many maybe we
turned too many on
okay well i know where the fuse box is
it might be underneath these stairs too
because it's quite a large map so it
would be mean if they didn't put more
than one generator in
oh it's not down under here nope the
lights are [ __ ]
all right well let's go to the other
stairs that's where we need to go
anyways oh there's a door here that we
didn't open
there's a few doors that we didn't open
this map is ginormous
i know
jennifer miller are you here hello
did you ring this phone
i'm trying to find the staircase we came
up on but that's the one i just came up
on it's not down there brayden
i'm sure it's not next to it
i don't know where it is i found it
it's got cold i found where she is
on this staircase it's chilly on the
staircase
yep she's here jennifer miller i'm
coming for you
okay so my emf reader does nothing then
it's it's chilly here i've gone up and
down this one multiple times and i
haven't seen nothing
also this isn't where the generator is i
need to find the other staircase
jennifer miller i'm gonna make you feel
silly
okay so i'm gonna once we find that
generator i'll just put my emf reader
away then
um yep that's not me and that was you
calling your name so if i die because of
you then screw you
just be calm
do you want to talk with us
not right now thanks oh spaghettios
it's freezing temperatures
she's coming for me i think i might be
dead i might be dead
i think i'm going to die
[ __ ] me i'm dead
is she gone you see
i can see my corpse
you killed my friend [ __ ] nothing
detected
oh my god the phone's going off again
i'm just getting out
oh my god uh can you actually pick up
that phone
that's really freaky what you want me to
go back
if you want or you can just get out of
here
okay i'll go back you don't have to no
i'll go back you're dead now you can you
can give me a heads up
when she's around i have my ghost friend
i'm going left no i'm going right right
is that where the generator is though
oh it's your dead body
i don't know your kid
i don't see you on the camera
can you you're supposed to be in the
school with me so you can have a look
and see what's happening
oh i'll stand in the van oh my god what
the hell
i'm coming i'm coming
right i went to the wrong staircase no
the [ __ ] sure it's not right
braden that's what i've been looking for
for like half an hour
oh the generator i can't
i can't see my ghost fighting because
it's a black book i just came here for
the
uh generator even though i can't find
light switch for this
hallway
oh beautiful
oh beautiful pose
so the book is just up here on the
stairs
it's right on this corner
[Music]
what
is it where is that are you a robot
oh i think you're dead
are you dead too are we dead friends
should we do one more and then call it a
night did i say that last time
yeah but if you want to do one more i
just want to try
i want i want the spirit box to work
oh sorry that was me oh it's oh it's
lightning outside
i found a key i don't know what i need
it for bread basket
not spooky vars it's here
it's definitely here how how do you know
frozen temperatures
not freezing but low ten nine eight okay
well my emp is not
doing in the tan where are you in the in
spooky room
no i've just come back i'm gonna go get
the uv light
is anyone here with me
is there a light on or something would
you like to talk to me
yes there's a light on you guys
there you go
would you like to talk to me
how old are you
nothing here show me a sign
maybe come more into the kitchen like
around the table
there you go show me a sign
there we go bit of activity now um um
someone just await one someone said my
name someone said jail someone said jail
someone said jill someone said jill it's
still my name who's jill
braden oh i don't know who jill is
are you jill i don't know
he said kill him he's so cute
he's so cute
okay i'm going back i'm going back i'm
scared i'm coming back i'm going back
sorry i cut that conversation short i
thought you called me by another
person's name i got jealous
did you just say something else because
i can't i can't understand
you activity's going again
how old are you you're an adult
that's nice i'm of age as well shall we
have um
alcohol together i'm i'm going
so spirit box i think we have everything
he said he's an adult yeah we use the
spirit box
i'm happy
he's an adult and he wants to kill to
kill
or he likes a girl called jill one of
the two
oh no we haven't done the crucifix i
think
i think you should go back in
it's a mare let's read it about the
mares yeah i'm having a man with this
a mare is the source of nightmares
making its most powerful in the dark
a mayor will have an increased chance of
attacking the dark turn the lights on
around the mayor will lower its chance
to attack
i panicked what are you doing to me
yeah okay
let's see if let's see if it does work
with both of us together
i don't think he will he said something
did you hear that
yeah what did you say to me can you
repeat that please
can you please i know you're an adult
can you say something else
how long have you lived here
eight years that's a long time
what do you want
are you a dog or a cat man
e i don't understand what it's saying
tea or coffee
it's saying e where did you go
i left oh
all right
are you dead
are you dead no
no no what happened
i got a picture i got a picture
it's just a shadow is it shadow of you
no it's it's the thing ah
that's cool though so that's the best
bits of phasmophobia for you
and i'm sure i'll play more in the near
future make sure to follow me
all of my links are in the description
down below
and i do live stream every thursday at 9
00 pm
bst so i'll see you there have a lovely
day or evening
bye